[Music]  hope you're ready it'll be here any  minute is that a rifle you don't know  what a rifle looks like it's just swords  were your thing and guns were mine but I  guess we were both doing guns now I just  didn't know that I see it within you  fear jealousy betrayal this is our duty  to cleanse the universe of this weakness  you know they told me you people were  conceited douchebags but that isn't true  at all  dude I'm using my wrong  [Music]  so we saving the galaxy we're really  gonna be able to jack up my price it for  two-time galaxy savers  [Music]  sometimes the thing you're searching for  your whole life  it's right there by your side all along  you're right  [Music]  listen maybe her  after all these years I've found you and  who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter  that was awesome